for trevor williams will shine a
spotlight on trevor he's the starting
pitcher for the cubs this afternoon
smith comes in hitting at a 267 clip
there's a pitch and that ball's ripped
and that's a fair ball into the left
field corner extra bases over to play
his wisdom and heading into second base
with a double standing up is paving
smith his 20th double of the year one
out two base hit your d back starter
today the lefty caleb smith the win over
the pirates his last timeout last monday
lead off walk for contreras and the cubs
and that'll bring up chris bryant here
in the bottom half of the first inning
the pitch to bryant
swinging a high fly ball deep left
center this ball is back near the war
though
a two-run homer cubs lead two to nothing
yeah souvenir time
first inning ambush
contreras works the walk
bryant provides the jog
the old walking tron
two run cub lead 102 miles an hour off
the bat for chris bryant home run number
17. 84 mile an hour slider maybe trying
to go back foot and just didn't bury it
down and in enough and we've talked a
lot about chris brian's swing path
uppercut swing meeting the trajectory of
the pitch and so many of his home runs
have a high
arching graceful
parabola and it'll bring up anthony
rizzo the glorious day here in the
friendly friendly conference rizzo
swings and drives one to deep right
field this is gone
back to back home runs for the cubs
first bryant now rizzo three to nothing
cubs over the diamondbacks inside heater
to riz
and he just drops the head of the bat on
it this just a line drive bullet
down the right field line fair by about
20 feet
and the cubs take a three-nothing lead
oh to the count on him the pitch from
smith
swing and a miss strike him out marshall
doesn't have to tag him or holliday
doesn't as bias heads back to the deck
out one out well that's the first down
for caleb smith and now he'll face
patrick wisdom
and caleb smith after the back-to-back
home runs against consecutive strikeouts
for round number two
cabrera leads off here's the o2 check
swing did he go yes he did
that's a strikeout for twitter williams
his first of the day david peralta
checks in left-handed batting outfielder
college football backfield breaking ball
called strike three as that one folks
right into the zone peralta did not like
the call but two away here in the top
half of the second in a short stop nick
ahmed at the plate he hits from the
right side the 2-2
swinging him in strike three trevor
williams has just struck out the side
here their pitching was phenomenal
keeping them in horner strikes out
swinging
on a high fastball that would have been
ball four third strikeout recorded by
smith
and two up two down here on the cap
second
williams the 3-2 offering to smith
called strike three
two away dalton varsio in the lead off
spot blocking it all out the last couple
of days
punches that one the other way away from
the shift and no play
for bodhi down there var shows the board
with that speed smith has retired the
first two contreras and brian on a
couple of nice plays at third by cabrera
man he gets rizzo swinging for strike
three and that's the uh fourth strike
out of the ball game for smith now has
gone nine up nine down since the first
three reached and scored we handed the
fourth at wrigley three nothing comes on
the backs rodeo network dorothy gale
award no place like home for trevor
williams
calhoun swings and misses and a high
fastball out number two
strikeout number five for trevor
williams and smith ready to go against
baez
and here's another strikeout caleb smith
has punched out five he set down 10
straight here's the pitch on the way
marishnik strikes three throw down to
first safe
getting back in is wisdom strikeout
number six for caleb smith
and two down to the inning cody found
out to first his first time smith
delivers bodhi swings hits one in the
air deep to left field way back
gone
welcome back david bodie points to the
sky with his right hand as he rounds
second a two-run home run david bodie
giving the cubs off five-nothing lead
here in the fourth
yeah a little floating curveball
one two count
and the pitch
swinging at a miss he strike him out
ball was up
strikeout number seven in the afternoon
for caleb smith
and two out here on the count fifth
inning go on pitch coming and that ball
is lifted in the air to the left
brawled it
under it david's still on the move still
on the move and makes a catch and then
tumbles over the railing down the left
field lined into the seats
and they're helping him up see if he's
okay here
and the out was made david's got a smile
on his face and he gets a nice hand from
the wrigley faithful he caught the ball
and then went up and over but hung on to
it and that's the outer rizzo to end
this
cup fifth inning here against another
one here cole calhoun and all the
offense against williams
and cole calhoun dunks it down the line
there's a lead-off single good start to
the seventh as drew below for two they
start today in third base with two
strikes on his drew here one out in the
seventh that's six strikeouts
working in the seventh inning
there's a ground ball left side that's a
base hit nicely done
right down the line over to get it the
left fielder wisdom stopping at second
calhoun
two on one out of this seventh inning
trevor is going to be congratulated by
his teammates he pitched very well today
and it's his ball game to win here at
wrigley field
ortega takes a long look at the cubs
third base coach willie harris gets the
sign the one to ortega bunch toward
their beautiful bunt
and that throw is not gonna be on time
you cannot put down a bunt any better
than raphael ortega just did here by azo
for three in the game with a couple of
punch outs
shattered the bat
bare handed by escobar hey got him
and baez is down he's hurt
that's okay
he went down pretty hard coming over
that first base bag a 3-2 to peralta
from maples
ball for you missed inside laid playoff
block to start the night andrew young
way to pinch hit home run yesterday in
the ball game of the ninth inning
[Applause]
andrew young
drops one into right center here comes
peralta d-backs get a run on the board
and they're still alive
kimbrell brings it
playable for bryant and wright
he's got it
cubs win the ball game
five to one the final trevor williams
over caleb smith
cubs win the series two out of three win
the season series
four games to two